en el vídeo pasado ya platicamos acerca
de las dos formas en las cuales podemos
financiar una compañía una era a través
de capital que básicamente era
conseguirnos un socio que nos iba a
acompañar en las buenas y en las malas y
la otra era a través de deuda que
básicamente era pedir un préstamo por el
cual teníamos que pagar una tasa de
interés sin importar qué sucede a través
del tiempo van ahorita lo que quiero
hacer es ser un poco más concreto y ver
estos tipos de financiamiento en que se
traducen ya en el mercado de valores
entonces quiero hablar un poco más
acerca de las acciones y de los bonos
para eso déjame pagar pasar acá abajo y
hacer otra vez una hoja de balance de
una compañía
de este lado tenemos el activo a la
derecha tenemos el capital y como la
compañía ahora sí está endeudada tiene
tiene pasivo de este lado y supongamos
que el capital está dividido en 10
millones de acciones va 10 millones de
acciones que el lado izquierdo de la
hoja de balance vale 10 millones de
pesos
y que esta deuda vale 6 millones de
pesos 6 millones de pesos entonces esta
empresa ha pedido préstamos hasta por 6
millones y cuánto queda para el capital
pues bueno tenemos que el activo va a
ser igual al pasivo más el capital así
que de esta forma esto que queda de
capital son 4 millones de pesos estos 4
millones están divididos equitativamente
en estos 10 millones de acciones y de
este modo más o menos cuesta como 40
centavos cada una vale 40 centavos bueno
entonces aquí tenemos el capital y el
capital está representado por acciones
entonces aquí son acciones que los
puedes pensar como papelitos pero
ahorita ya todo es muy electrónico pero
son acciones que tienen escrito un
simbolito de la compañía le voy a poner
aquí compra que digamos supongamos que
es el símbolo de esta compañía no sé si
haya una que sea compra pero bueno
entonces lo que lo que este papelito
dice es que nosotros somos un socio de
esta compañía y que podemos ayudar a su
administración por otro lado un bono acá
arriba
un bono
es un certificado que dice que la
compañía nos debe dinero entonces es
bueno o sea esta deuda de 6 millones se
pudo haber obtenido ya sea por un
préstamo bancario verdad ya vamos al
banco y negociamos una tasa de interés
no sé del 5% anual o lo que sea porque
ya somos una empresa establecida pero
eso es financiarse por deuda pero a
través como de un mercado privado así
como acá abajo podemos financiarnos a
través de capital público aquí arriba
también podemos hacer emisión de bonos
entonces podemos ir con distintas
personas y decirles mira vamos a
venderte deuda de nuestra compañía y te
vamos a pagar intereses después y
entonces digamos no sé que estos seis
millones que tenemos deuda están
repartidos en voy a poner en seis mil
bonos
en 6000 bonos y cada uno de ellos de mil
pesos si verdad seis mil por mil son
seis millones ok entonces de modo
similar como aquí tenemos un papelito de
acción acá podemos pensar en un bono
como en un papelito que tiene
pues no se dice compañía xz y ser
acompañada xz y dice que es de mil pesos
de mil pesos entonces más o menos se
vería algo de este estilo y lo que este
papelito representa si yo lo tuviera
ahorita aquí en mi cajón del escritorio
es que esta compañía en alguna fecha
futura que se llama el vencimiento del
vencimiento
me va a pagar mil pesos y aquí te puedes
preguntar ok pero qué pasó con el
interés dónde quedó el interés
interés pues hay varias formas en las
cuales podemos reflejar el interés a
través de los bonos uno puede hacer que
al principio yo solo le haya dado este
quinientos pesos a la compañía por decir
algo entonces le pagué 500 pesos al
principio y como al final me tiene que
dar mil pesos digamos dentro de cinco
años entonces aquí se refleja el interés
verdad en este caso tendríamos un bono
de cero cupones o un bono sin cupones
ahorita ya me estoy metiendo con un poco
de terminología sería bueno a apuntarlo
por aquí verdad entonces sería un bono
cupones
funes y un bono sin cupones es
básicamente que no me van a pagar nada
intermedio que todo me lo van a pagar
hasta el final va desde a todo esto de
los bonos es un tema complicadísimo a lo
mejor debería ser toda una lista de
estos de bonos y de diferentes tipos de
bonos que hay que sí tienen cupones o
que si no los tienen y qué tipo de tasa
de interés se usa que si la compuesta o
qué otra se puede hacer entonces que eso
son cosas un poco complicadas ahorita no
no nos vamos a meter con los detalles
técnicos después lo podemos ver pero si
te das cuenta los bonos en esencia si
funcionan distinto que las acciones o
sea las acciones por un lado se secos se
cotizan y sant en la bolsa mexicana de
valores y entonces puedes buscar el
valor de una acción fácilmente en
internet está en internet
internet sin embargo con los bonos es un
poco más difícil también son valores y
también se pueden vender porque pues es
un activo verdad es algo que me promete
que la empresa me va a pagar cierto
dinero entonces este bono si yo
estuviera urgencia de liquidez podría
venderlo en 800 pesos por decir algo
pero es mucho más difícil saber cuánto
cuesta un bono de hecho a lo mejor así
los hacen no sé si sea para que no haya
tanta transparencia pero no estoy seguro
intenta buscarlo en internet y es muy
difícil ver más o menos en cuánto está
cotizado el bono de una cierta compañía
pero bueno más allá de la búsqueda de
precios otra gran diferencia es que un
bono simplemente es una promesa de pago
le voy a poner aquí promesa de pago
promesa de pago que la compañía debe
satisfacer pero acá abajo una acción
representa mucho más una acción
representa pues que se puede participar
en la administración de cierta forma
participar
administración entonces no es una
promesa en realidad una acción no es te
voy a pagar tanto dinero es tú eres
socio de mi compañía si me ayudas a
administrar la o bueno si crecen que
nosotros la vamos a administrar bien
entonces nos va a ir bien a todos vale
entonces ahí tenemos una diferencia más
entre bonos y acciones y déjame
plantearte una pregunta para que la
pienses de aquí al siguiente vídeo que
es la siguiente imagínate qué pues ya
tenemos esta compañía está financiada
por capital y también está financiada
por deuda pero esta compañía de repente
cae en bancarrota bancarrota
no voy a poner carita triste de
bancarrota hay que pegar que esa carita
triste hasta tiene una lágrima entonces
esta compañía cae en bancarrota y bueno
debo de ser un poco más específico de
hecho hay dos tipos de bancarrota hay
una bancarrota en la cual ya no se puede
hacer nada todo este activo de acá ya no
funciona ya no podemos hacer operaciones
del negocio y entonces lo tenemos que
vender para satisfacer estas
obligaciones las de deuda y las de
capital se le conoce como el capítulo 7
en eeuu y la otra es la bancarrota del
capítulo 11 que tiene que ver con que la
compañía aún sirve y tiene que
reestructurar su deuda habita para que
sea más fácil de explicar vamos a
suponer que cae en una bancarrota del
capítulo 7 y el lado de acá solo vale
bueno ya se venden todos los activos
pero como hay que venderlos
inmediatamente se venden nada más que 8
millones y la pregunta que te quiero
hacer es cómo se reparten estos 8
millones a la derecha o sea a quienes se
les tiene que pagar primero a aquellos
que colaboraron con deuda oa aquellos
que son los socios de la compañía
entonces la pregunta es
quienes tienen prioridad aquellos que
dieron un préstamo con una cierta tasa
de interés o aquellos que son socios y
son dueños de la compañía que son dueños
del capital y la administra bueno te lo
dejo para que lo pienses y en el próximo
vídeo hablaremos de la bancarrota del
capítulo 7 y después de la bancarrota
del capítulo 11 nos vemos hasta la
próxima